Let's go to our next caller from the two six
two area code.
Who's calling today from two six two
Oh, hi David.
Can you hear me?
Yes I can.
Hey, I'm one of your right wind sands and
I'm wondering if you have any idea of when
all of this a low hanging fruit that our generation
is into when we'll finally pick that rank
choice vote cut the military in half term
limits.
This sort of thing.
I don't have an answer unfortunately.
I mean, I, I would, I would like to see, uh,
many of those, uh, ideas implemented soon.
Uh, I agree that they are low hanging fruit
in the sense that these are pretty obvious
things that we should be doing.
It's not low hanging fruit in the sense that
it's easy to accomplish politically.
There would be big opposition.
So I don't know in what sense if you mean
low hanging fruit as like, Hey, we should
obviously do these things.
I'm with you.
If you mean low hanging fruit in it should
have been easy to do them already.
I don't know about that.
Well, I mean, uh, you know, I have plenty
of left wing and right wind fans and they
are not fans friends and they all seem to
agree on, on this list.
But um, yeah, why hasn't it happened?
Well, a lot of those things challenge the
institutions of power.
So term limits.
Everybody who got in got in without term limits.
They're not particularly incentivized to put
in place term limits that might get them out
of office.
A lot of the people that got in got in supporting
the military industrial complex being funded
by defense contractors, et cetera.
So they're not really the people who are going
to go in and cut the size of the military
in half.
So you have to understand that, that there's
a, there's unaligned incentives there.
Well, hopefully if we can change those incentives.
Can I ask one other quick question?
Yeah.
Um, so I have some money left for me in a
Vanguard healthcare account and I'm wondering
what will happen to that sort of account,
uh, is some sort of Medicare for all those
tests.
Um, my sense is that any accounts that are
for sort of like predesignated healthcare
spending, so I think this would include like
HSHS and so on and so forth.
I assume that if Medicare for all, uh, takes
place, all of that money will be a sort of
allowed to be moved out of those sequestered
funds that have to be used for health care.
It's a healthcare mutual fund.
So,
Oh, we just invest in healthcare companies.
Yeah.
You're going to want to get out of that.
I think if Medicare for all passes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right.
Good to know.
All right.
Very good.
Thank you so much for the call.
I appreciate it.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, uh, don't hang up because
we'll go right back to the phones right after
the short break